hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to clickhole quizzes
now click whole is a website full of
valuable information it's a website with
articles written that are completely
serious and there was this quiz on here
that caught my eye called how many of
these things have you yelled while
having mind-blowing sex with RL Stein RL
Stein being the author of the popular
book series goosebumps and obviously out
of all the quizzes that were on this
site this one spoke to me the most it
practically screamed at me
while I was having mind-blowing sex with
RL Stein I don't think that this quiz
will be family-friendly at all
so with that in mind all the
family-friendly people get the [ __ ] out
how many of these things have you
screamed out loud during rapture sex
with [ __ ] me until I can't read you
spooky there are two things you excel at
RL Stein sex and goosebumps of which the
latter gives me the forum the former
gives me the latter hey are you the guy
who wrote goosebumps cool now let's get
back to having great sex oh yeah I
forgot I've screamed it's definitely
this hair you got you know I wouldn't go
into that if I didn't know holy [ __ ]
I can't believe I'm good you taught me
to love reading and now you've taught me
to love docking oh god the neighbors now
I've said that this is not even close to
the disappointment that Louis Sachar
said it would be who's Lewis car young
adult mystery comedy author best known
for the wayside school series and
award-winning novel holes I have neither
read the book holes or seen the movie
hole
so can't say that I have not said that
no I have not said that if they gave out
Coretta Scott King awards for sex
you'd win one for the sex we're having
right now I don't know what the Coretta
Scott King award is oh the wife of
Martin Luther King jr. Wow out of
dignity for Coretta Scott King I'm gonna
not check that one movie be muy bien
Senor Stein but why don't you that was
definitely a concern they grabbed in my
mind
god damn RL Stein you sure can [ __ ] yep
please continue whispering I'm gonna
base a goose bumps book on that bro
you're successfully [ __ ] my reading a
little comprehension down to a
third-grade level I don't like that
reference Stephen King is a better
writer than you but far less sexually no
I disagree on the key there's no way
he's better this sex is as pleasurable
as your books were scary to me it's fine
das east verboten when I saw the TV
adaptation of goosebumps I thought
there's simply no way the author of the
source material is good at sex but now I
know I was wrong who is responsible yes
of course I've said these things who's
responsible for this probably at the
bottom Louis Sachar said you'd use way
too much hot wax but I think you're
using the perfect amount mm-hmm exactly
[ __ ] Louisa Karp non that way your
artistic credibility
in comparison to your 100% vertical
penis really enjoying the sex right now
if I wasn't 117 years old I love for the
sex to get me pregnant with an RL Stein
baby
well that one obviously just doesn't
apply to me does RL stand for raw we
both my parents died when I was young
and I didn't have many friends growing
up but your books made me feel less
alone in the world in fact they inspired
me to pursue writing myself and while I
wish I could go to school for it I can't
afford to because all the money I make
it my custodial job goes into taking
care of my grandmother who is very ill
right now she raised me and I love her
and I will never give up on her but the
day she gets better I'm going to apply
to the Iowa Writers Workshop this is my
dream and it's all because of your books
so thank you for inspiring me oh yes
love them balls nothing gets me hotter
than when you fan my bear Gooch with it
this matters this matters I I don't
remember if this particular book was
fanned on my Gooch is what I'm trying to
understand here hmm no I don't think
that was my Gooch that received say
cheese and dye adult film actor John
Holmes would have played you in the 2015
goosebumps film if he'd been alive and
it would have been the perfect casting
who is John Holmes please don't show me
a penis seems to be dead man where are
your glasses as you give me a hickey in
the shape of your autograph what a
talent that would be lesbian crap I
probably asked for it but you know I
didn't receive it is the thing Louis
Sachar implied that you would lay there
and take it like a sack of potatoes but
the reality is that we've made love on
top of every surface inside this
and just tremendous yeah uh-huh I mean
this is a compliment but you have sex
like you've never written a children's
book your books once gave me turned out
traumatic nightmares and this process
[Music]
the only other time I've quivered this
much was when I was read goosebumps and
that was with fear this quiver I'll do
that thing where you tell your glasses
down grunt and pawed the ground like a
bull before you've sold over 400 million
books across the world yet your most
impressive accomplishment was your
strategic use of the showerhead during
foreplay yep Robert Lauren Stein you are
grounded for making love to me this well
yep big squeal yep thank you mr. Stein I
always think okay cool good let's get
the results let's get out of here you
shouted an average amount of these when
our outside was making sweet hot sex to
you you shattered your appreciation but
were you simply average amount of time
you seemed as equally focused on letting
him know it was great sex as you were on
participating in the coitus itself all
right congratulations I have a great sex
with or else I wait okay I'm gonna go
for a way to go for that all of them
Jesus Christ who wrote this this is
outstanding okay here we go
wow you've shouted a whole lot well when
RL Stein was giving you the best loving
of your life you let him know it loud
proud and often it must have meant a lot
to you to hear how much you enjoy
wait there's one more we got out of
resent this you were dead sighs the
dirty on you in a way that would make
even the most famous porn stars feel
secular you did not say a word
you're probably far too busy basking the
five hour long full-body knocking your
loins with the precision focused a
couple you barely shouted anything when
I was [ __ ] must have been tough to
think of anything to say when one of the
greatest children's authors of all times
making you melt into a puddle of
yourself before whoo-hoo who wrote this
it doesn't say it doesn't say who's
responsible hero oh yeah I'm never gonna
look at our else today the same way
again nod what a man okay cool
yeah thank you for watching and
continuing with me on this journey if
you for some reason want to see more
click hole quizzes I can't promise that
they'll all be of such a sexual nature
but clickhole quizzes are notoriously
funny for some reason I don't know why
but this one was particularly ticklish
to my funny bone and other bones wink
wink so thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want to see more leave a
like let me know in the comments down
below
figure out some way to let me know start
slamming buttons down there below go at
it like RL Stein would go at your nether
regions and if you do want to see more
subscribe and you may see more in the
future
- thanks and as always I will see you in
the next video bye-bye